big applause for mr joey diaz yes
[Applause]
let's keep it going for the beautiful
young lady
if you guys are looking for comedy
tonight this ain't the [ __ ] night to
come here
all right so i hope you're not looking
at ha ha in hee hee because tonight is
not yaha
i'm taking you into deep waters after i
tell you this story you might not
[ __ ] like me you might take your name
off twitter
i will not be your facebook friend there
will be no more [ __ ] zooville
or mob wars and none of that [ __ ]
so i'm just telling you right now if you
dig me leave now
because i'm taking it to deep waters all
right
the day i kidnapped vela
was the best and the worst day of my
life
depending on how you look at it
again the day i kidnapped
vela was either the worst or the best
day of my life
you guys are looking at me going [ __ ]
you kidnap somebody that's [ __ ]
tremendous
i didn't know i was kidnapping somebody
i was doing an old-fashioned american
drug rip
you bring the drugs i bring the cash and
i take home the drugs and the [ __ ]
cash
but somewhere in the american law book
they call the kidnapping so [ __ ] it
leave it there give it a name you know
what i'm saying
this is 2012. this is i'm gonna take you
back to november
18th of 1987 the day i kidnapped
vela but before i kidnap vela i got to
tell you my state of mind
just so you [ __ ] know
january of 87 i left aspen colorado
where i thought i was a drug dealer
because i ended up
i was [ __ ] making a bank and then i
started snorting again and also i owe
like 60 000
and i got paranoid like that paranoia
stage where i [ __ ] would throw coke
away
and i would it was [ __ ] horrible so i
had to leave i knew they were watching
me they were watching me
i knew all that stuff and then one night
i just packed up and [ __ ] left with
my girlfriend the dog
and it was the scariest night i had a
gun and we kept stopping at hotels but
we were going to hotel and we'd do a
line and we get paranoid so we checked
the [ __ ] out
i must have spent 2 000 hotels that
first [ __ ] night
this went on from aspen all the way to
boulder and we went back to boulder we
got there over the holidays and we kind
of stayed with her mother and her father
they [ __ ] hated me
they were polish and i'm cuban they
didn't like me to [ __ ] at all you follow
me
but you know she was happy they didn't
know that we had just done all these
crimes so we're sitting there eating
christmas dinner everybody's happy
jingle bells
jingle bells and i'm sitting there going
[ __ ]
if these [ __ ] knew you know i'm
saying there wouldn't be no jingle bells
in this house right now
but you know life went on and i got a
job i got a job as a shagger at a body
shop making
390 an hour times 80 hours a week
fixing cars and washing cars and just
all i wanted was to have a job and i
wanted my life to be normal
you know i got an apartment i borrowed
money from a friend of mine in jersey an
apartment
i got a job i got some clothes and i got
this shitty [ __ ] job and i did it for
like two months
but it was uh you were doing we worked
for a car dealership
a couple of them subaru he had a couple
different dealers
so i would do the cars for all the
different dealers and i i got to sign
subarus
so i became friends with the sales
manager subaru guy's name was pinto
little italian guy from jersey a real
[ __ ] scumbag
he was i didn't know it you know but he
liked me he always talked to me and [ __ ]
and he goes dog you should sell [ __ ]
cars over here and i'm like ah i don't
want to [ __ ] sell cars
you know [ __ ] that [ __ ] and then they
promoted me to a detailer and i was
really making nice cash now like a grand
a week
i was working like a [ __ ] six
days a week but i was making some cash
and this guy kept asking me we're gonna
come over and sell cars i'm like no i
don't wanna [ __ ] sell cars
i'm finally got my [ __ ] together i was
actually going to school at night to see
you boulder continuing education
i wasn't doing too bad no matter what
position i was in
i was always going to [ __ ] classes at
night even if i was selling coke and i
was a junkie
i would always manage to get to health
and [ __ ] fitness
class for three credits i don't know how
the [ __ ] i did it at night you know what
i'm saying
i started at colorado mountain college
and i did that for like a year and a
half
in colorado and all of a sudden when i
went to cu boulder i transferred in and
one day at boulder they said to me hey
you can't take these continuing ed
classes you have too many credits you
have to transfer into the universe and
i'm like
they're never going to [ __ ] take me
into the university so i go
try it so i tried it joey diaz and they
gave me the application you're done
you're in no [ __ ] danger
but if your name was jose diaz boy is
there opportunity for you
at this white school you know what i'm
saying because you're like the fourth
latino so it would be just [ __ ]
rocking for you
we'll give you money your car you get
your dick sucked you have to do homework
you know what i'm saying
you'll be living like a football player
[ __ ] it
i'm like ain't this a [ __ ] [ __ ] put
jose down whatever i'm coming to school
with morocco you know me
as long as they're paying i'll do
whatever the [ __ ] you want me to do i
don't give a [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
as long as i could snort coke and
[ __ ] do my thing and yeah oh [ __ ]
ricky ricardo
i'm going there i'll talk with a [ __ ]
accent how are you today
oh [ __ ] it but you gotta pay me [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying
son
so i go to this pinto guy like he's
busting my balls dog you're going to
school
at night you should really come sell
cars in the daytime so finally one day i
go you know what [ __ ]
i'll come on sunday you know and i went
home that week and i had a suit and a
shirt i dusted off
and i went in there sunday and he goes
[ __ ] just go out there they gave me
like a five minute training
course i knew nothing about subarus
they're like [ __ ] it's got a hood
it's got a seat it's got an engine it's
four-wheel drive
some guy jim from detroit i love this
[ __ ] he had no tooth
guy was real you know what i'm saying
like he had scars on his forehead he
didn't give a [ __ ]
and this guy was a top guy he's like
this is how you sell cars do this
she goes god try it the first [ __ ]
day i sold three cars i made a thousand
bucks
it's like what do you want to do i said
let me call the [ __ ] body shop and
tell them to suck my dick you understand
me
i gotta work all week for a grand i made
a grand selling three [ __ ] cars i'm
in i went
it's a fashion bar i got a credit card i
got like 19 suits
watch the suit watch the suit you know
what i'm saying
i was ready and [ __ ] right so i started
selling [ __ ] cars you know
and i'm a natural like this [ __ ] i'm
just out there talking to people and
laughing and busting people's balls
and i was making seven eight thousand a
[ __ ] month
with a suit on they gave me a car to
drive around
and for the first time i wasn't a
criminal no more i was like oh my god
look at this i found my calling
you know i get up in the morning i work
hard i send postcards i call people
and i sell them [ __ ] cars you know
and you have some time off during the
week i could hike i could play with my
dog plus i got [ __ ] money man
when you're 24 years old and you got
seven grand that 10 grand a month in
your pocket
it ain't bad and i was clean and sober i
mean i was smoking dope and lifting
weights
but i wasn't eating valiums and snoring
coke and nothing like that
so finally i'm rocking and rolling at
the subaru dealership and one day i said
listen my buddy wants to buy a car sell
them this car and they go it's 500 bucks
then a week later my buddy calls me
because dog i got a bill for 1500 bucks
these guys were thieves
i said listen the guy wants his 1500
back they're like nah we're not going to
get back to him
i went and i got a [ __ ] uh one of
those things a sledge hammer and i got
a top one of the car and like four
customers and i said if you don't get my
money back
i'm gonna start smashing [ __ ]
windshields in this [ __ ]
and they said all right we'll give you
your money back so i gave me back my 15
but they sent me home for the day
and on the way home i seen this chrysler
plymouth place that was like a little
white mom and pop store
it was a dodge place where they sold
trucks to farmers and the chrysler
plymouth place they had like three cars
the the k car had just brought him back
but it was a nice door they gave me a
nice hour so i stopped in there and i
applied
and they go come back monday i told the
subaru store to suck my dick so i said
[ __ ] it
you know a subaru store was just a bunch
of [ __ ] criminals man
and once i realized they were all
criminals i felt shitty about myself
i was like i mean they had a guy norm
that was in and out of jail and he come
back to sell cars the next day like
nothing
and he used to teach me how to piss test
in those days
this guy used to tie a douche bottle
around his [ __ ] body
with the hose to his dick and he would
pee in the [ __ ] thing with the
[ __ ]
douche thing this guy was a genius and
there was another guy carlos was a bank
robber
and he was robbing banks at lunchtime
while he was selling cars you understand
it
this [ __ ] was from boston he was
italian and cuban
one day i'm at lunch [ __ ] high in the
back smoking a [ __ ] pipe
and the place is surrounded by swat i'm
like what the [ __ ] they were looking for
carlos
this is a real car dealership they would
throw people's keys on the roof and [ __ ]
this is crazy these [ __ ]
started drinking at 10 in the morning
this was no joke these mother no
licenses
dui's but these guys sold [ __ ]
cars i mean this was eight salesmen who
sold [ __ ] 300 cars a month
we were [ __ ] gorillas out there and
you had to trip people and they would
tackle you
and they would say things to you like
your suit don't look right or your
breath stinks so they would [ __ ] get
in your head
it's called pissing on your leg these
guys were geniuses
you know so i i mean i i [ __ ] it i don't
want to be a criminal
i just want to make money and be a mom
and pop [ __ ]
i go over to chrysler it's the american
way you know what i'm saying dodge the
american way
american [ __ ] people i walked in
there there was not one american in
there
everything but a [ __ ] american and
there was sniffling too everybody was
sniffling the first day that i'm like oh
[ __ ]
everybody snorts [ __ ] coke
everybody gets high the [ __ ] owner
like the manager was like this old
jewish guy his name was artie and he
would be sniffling all day but this
[ __ ] knew how to sell a car he
was a jew
he knew and he taught me bro and i
[ __ ] got good this [ __ ] used
to start with a credit app first
and break a [ __ ] down
psychologically like he's like if they
tell you the
personal [ __ ] then you own these
[ __ ] he would he was a jew dog
you follow me old school
he wore the yarmulke and had diamonds on
it that means he was a real [ __ ] jew
[ __ ] it i'm wearing diamonds on my [ __ ]
blood ones i don't give a [ __ ]
i got a finger on one hang and that's
i'm gonna [ __ ]
this guy was the last of the real
[ __ ] jews it could be
ten to nine and a guy could be driving
on a bike let's go out and sell that
[ __ ] a car and he would sell him
a car i got no money i don't give a [ __ ]
we'll drive you to your house and get
your wallet
this guy was amazing [ __ ] salesman i
remember one night this asian guy came
in and he was like
what do you want to do and the guy's
like i think i want to buy a car he
didn't even [ __ ] around he goes you got
money
and the guy had one of those things and
he opened it up and he had i got fifteen
thousand he goes [ __ ] it
let's go let's sell this he took me
aside let's sell this [ __ ] car
what the deal was we sold him a car but
the next day i had to drive him to a
chrysler place to get the car he wanted
this guy's an asian he's a freak he's
100 bucks take him to a strip club we're
going to get this guy for every dollar
he's [ __ ] got
on the way home i stopped at the charlie
whatever the ones that's naked where the
women's dance when you bring your own
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] started drinking that
ying yang juice he got all fired up in
there he was sweating and [ __ ]
he didn't want to leave how much for the
car eighteen thousand here's three
[ __ ] more
every ten minutes i hit him up for
another three g's he just kept giving me
travelers checked with mouzu tongues
pictures on it
[ __ ] this guy had real paper and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so
this star was [ __ ] crazy it was for
salesmen and everybody was [ __ ]
gacked up
so finally after a month i said you know
what [ __ ] it i'm gonna start doing blow
and it was the most [ __ ] crazy store
because two of the salesmen would do
blow and hide
so i would come in buy a gram give them
two bumps and i got rid of two salesmen
for the day
so now it was me and rob there was only
four of us i got to think like a jew
when you're around jews
so now i was robbed he was half a jew
but he snorted coke too
and he he used to be superstitious he
had a lucky red pen
so whenever he was selling the car he
put the red pen down i'd steal it
that's jew type [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying he'd come back where's my red
penna i have no [ __ ] idea
he would not sell that car he'd go to a
stationary store
and buy another parker pen i would take
the pens and just hide them in the
ceiling
just a torch every time he was in i roll
i'd steal a [ __ ] red pen i can't sell
a car without my red bed
i used to crack everybody i was captain
[ __ ] crack in there
then he started selling blow because he
couldn't make enough money at like nine
kids
he'd be sweating all day with glasses on
they'd be all [ __ ] up
but he didn't have the balls
he didn't have the balls to take the
coke home with him because of wife and
kids
so he would hide at the dealership you
can't do that [ __ ] around me
i figured them out one night i called
them like 11. you got anything now it's
at the dealership bang
the next day service opens at 6 15. i'm
there at 607 with a [ __ ]
flashlight and a [ __ ] a hat with a
light i'm looking for that [ __ ]
so i would take the coke take the coke
out and put aspirin in there and put the
back in the ceiling
he'd come in i watch him i'm like watch
this [ __ ] i'd watch him go into
the back i'd watch him reach take the
coke out of the ceiling
go on the bathroom they come out going
that coke ain't right something's wrong
and i'm [ __ ] dying you know i'm
saying
i'm dying i'm like this [ __ ] ain't
getting no headache today
[Laughter]
oh i would torture these dudes the whole
deal and already and then i found out
already the manager this 60 year old jew
was the [ __ ] dealer
he was getting coke sent to him right
from like bogota
and he had the chrysler store and the
dodge store hopping
and the dodge store was good old boys
you couldn't [ __ ] with those
[ __ ] that even go down there
because they were like ex-vietnam bets
like hamburger hill and [ __ ] like that
talking about eating people there was
one guy that would threaten you i'll
[ __ ] kill you if you don't buy a
goddamn car
buy this truck [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] nuts
so i became nuts this guy's name was
dale he was in hamburger hill
and we went to see the movie hamburger
hill when it came out he's like that's a
lie
he was yelling at the screen
he wanted to go i'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] camera guy up i'm like dawg he
didn't even
he's just up to eight dollars an hour
[ __ ] him
didi mao he hated [ __ ] everybody he
hated everybody he would insult me all
day for being cuban but he loved me i
knew he loved me you know
you spit [ __ ] people like you
ruining this [ __ ] country
but i loved it i loved it the [ __ ]
cubans they came over they
they cut the prices of cocaine it's he
was always
i love racist people you gotta i love
them
and i love when they're racist against
me that's why i laugh even harder
i love it i love all this this is this
dealership and the manager down there
was jim he was [ __ ] crazy too
this guy was having [ __ ] his wife was
that an sna manager
and he was [ __ ] her at work i mean
they were doing coke
and finally i got into an argument one
day with jim i said jim [ __ ] you he
almost went to blows and i quit
but by this time i was [ __ ] up i'm
gone i'm gone more than when i lived in
jersey i'm gone more than when i lived
in aspen
so i said [ __ ] i'm going back to subaru
with those criminals if i'm gonna be a
criminal i'm gonna go make criminal
money and i'm gonna go [ __ ] snort
coke
and die and drink and [ __ ] and do it
crash a demo and go to jail and come out
and sell cars and make ten thousand i
didn't give a [ __ ] i
i was already committed to this [ __ ] so
i went back they had fired peter behind
this new guy wayne and i loved this
[ __ ] from day one he was like an
old sons of anarchy type [ __ ]
he had tattoos and [ __ ] it was the 80s
nobody had tattoos this guy
he was cropping and he just dug me he
dug me used to call me the renegade
you're the [ __ ] cuban renegade i love
your people dog
i love your people i love you you're
[ __ ] all renegades and [ __ ]
so he understood me so he gave it to me
he took care of me
and there was a lot of new faces there
but this is one [ __ ] face that i
hadn't seen before
and his name was grella good looking
[ __ ] dude i was 24 he was maybe 26.
he had like a cut lip like he had
already been beat up a couple times
and you know he looked like he was up
for a couple days so here i was up for a
couple days he's up for a couple days so
obviously you just navigate to one
another you know what i'm saying and we
started talking and
i'm feeling them out but at the time you
know it's so [ __ ] up when you have
that kiss of death loser mentality
the better things are going you just
want to [ __ ] it up you know as bad as
things were they could have been worse
in new york
i could have been [ __ ] not sleeping
and carrying a gun and here i was just
selling cars making money and i was
still [ __ ] it up
but i would talk to my friends back home
you know in jersey and they go on skiing
and they're doing eight balls and having
orgies
and then i am in [ __ ] colorado
hanging out with a bunch of [ __ ]
farmers going to bed at 10 o'clock at
night
walking around campus with a book in my
hand i'm like [ __ ] this i'm 24.
i got to make a score and i'm going back
to jersey i'm gonna dump this chick
you know [ __ ] my friend that lives with
me out here from jersey i'm sick of this
goody-goody life
i need a [ __ ] score and this kid
comes over to me right after i said this
to my friend
i hang up the phone and say denver
against summit it's a monday night so a
dealership was quiet
so i would usually call long distance on
that night trust me i was a 24-hour
walking [ __ ] scam
you know i had a phone at the house but
i used long distances at the dealership
it was i was horrible i was a horrible
[ __ ] person
so now i'm sitting and i'm like how am i
going to get back home and this [ __ ]
fellow guy comes up to me one morning
and he goes hey man
can you give me a ride to a liquor store
i mean it was like [ __ ] nine o'clock
so i figured he needed cigarettes or
rolling papers but normal people [ __ ]
need in the morning you know
when we get to liquor store he goes hey
man you want something i go yeah get me
like a diet coke or a coke or whatever
he goes
you don't want no rum and i'm like no he
comes back with like a half gallon the
[ __ ] vodka he sits down and he starts
drinking it straight
and we go back to the dealership and
he's like you want to bump him so i knew
this guy was already trouble and i liked
it i'm like [ __ ] i'm gonna hang out with
this guy he's perfect
for me
i mean birds of a feather flock [ __ ]
together right
so we talked for about a week and one
thing goes you want to get me ride home
give him a ride home and he has no
license you know and he's telling me how
he got this dui
and he got quote for possession and
they're going to throw him in jail
he doesn't want to do time so his
roommate where he was staying had two
kilos of coke
and he was going to rob it sell it at
wholesale and move to arizona and start
a new life
somebody that's [ __ ] cool so he goes
if you know anybody that wants to buy
coke wholesale let me know
so we go upstairs and i go give me like
20 worth and he gives me like a [ __ ]
eight ball
and i go home and every bump i'm doing
at home my mind is going
and i'm like i'm gonna rob this
[ __ ] this is the
this is it you know at this point guys i
was robbing everything that wasn't
nailed down the five grand the month i
was making wasn't
even paying for nothing i was snorting
that up
i was going there in the mornings and
robbing the soda machine i mean i was
stealing so i mean i was [ __ ] a
24-hour
[ __ ] theft machine 24-hour
felonies every [ __ ] day my roommate
who was also from north bergen
was renting out the new cars to
strippers at the bus stop
on a daily rate and putting a plate on
it for the dealer
and i was i was getting a cut of that it
was 24
hour [ __ ] madness you know i would go
to the [ __ ] uh
uh boulder was not prepared for a
character like me i would
i'm telling you i would i walked out of
the [ __ ] mall one time with a cd
player radio shack
just picked it up and walked out with
the box
nobody stopped me nobody said nothing
you know i figured out how to steal by
not stealing
i would go to may dnf pick up a blanket
for 300 bring it to the tingle my mother
bought me this
i got three of them
and they look at it like
we don't have any other one really i
really wanted a blanket
and they're like well we can give you a
check of cash
i don't really need the cash but i'll
take it if you have it
and they put like 199 dollars and you
get 260 plus tax they even give you a
tax
i was going in there bringing back a
blanket and getting 200 that's the time
of espresso machines are just starting
to get hot i was joey espressos
everybody i knew had an expressional
machine even if they didn't drink
[ __ ] coffee i finagled one out of you
just give me 60 bucks bro
they're 200 new just give me 60. who do
you know somebody wants to come on they
want [ __ ] coffee there you are
everything i was a 24 hour selling
stealing
snorting [ __ ] crazy and i had a great
girlfriend
but she lived with her parents so she
would go home at 9 30 at night
and i would just go off the deep end
she'd come back like at seven with my
shirt iron
oh that was a good night's sleep i
hadn't slept for [ __ ] weeks
weeks i hadn't slept so this is my
[ __ ] mindset so
i'm thinking about this guy like a pork
chop right now i mean let's [ __ ]
face it at this time right now i was
just looking to [ __ ] kill somebody
i really was i was just looking to kill
somebody looking to kill myself at this
point
i just wanted to score i was still angry
about my mom dying
the drug situation i didn't have it good
i had to work for everything i had i was
angry like most kids are at 24 when they
got a [ __ ] work every day
you want a better life you wish you're a
kardashian you don't know what the [ __ ]
you want
but you know you don't want this at 24 i
had no family i had this girl i'm living
in boulder
surrounded by [ __ ] republicans i
don't [ __ ] know all these waspy [ __ ]
i don't know these [ __ ] people
i don't know these [ __ ] people i'm
from north bergen new jersey dog where
people look like they they [ __ ]
you know i don't know these [ __ ] nice
looking people that say good morning to
you in the morning you know what that's
like the first time somebody goes good
morning
you're like go [ __ ] yourself good
morning hey no good morning here i don't
know you [ __ ]
those people were nice [ __ ] people
man